our organs were not built to go into our
7s or ' 80s by the time we're in our 40s
to 50s we run into problems going from
head to toe I'd like to talk about how
organs and body parts Age and what we
can do about
it over the years our cells our organs
suffer from gradual wear and tear we age
but we're not defenseless let's start
with our
brain as we age our brain atrophies and
it's not problematic unless things pop
up that become problematic speech
disorders you've all heard of
Alzheimer's many of the causes of these
are not particularly clear our brain
starts to lose about 5% of its volume
per decade probably somewhere in the 30s
it decreases because of loss of number
of cells degeneration of the massive
tracks and fibers certain things can
lead to brain atrophy one of them is
vascular problems as we age make sure we
are on top of and checking our vascular
systems our ears you probably think you
have two of them in actuality we have
six ears three on one side three on the
other outer middle and the inner ear we
age in all of them in our outer ear our
cartilages and our tissues start to
droop it didn't devolve for hanging
Christmas tree ornaments by the time
you're well into your ears you'll be
able to wipe your chin with it the
middle ear has tiny little bones
whenever you have bones they come
together at joints and you know what
joints can get can you say arthritis
prusis or age related hearing loss can
be due to arthritis between your little
ear bones we get get to our inner ear we
have specialized hair cells and they
send signals to our vestibular clean
nerve that's how we hear that's how we
sense balance as we age hearing loss can
be due to death of the hair cells what
we call sensory neural hearing loss we
start to lose high frequency sounds
probably around 30 plus we do retain
most of all low frequency
sounds what what' you say I can't I
can't hear
[Music]
eyes as we age we start to get aspects
of what's called crespi Opia which is
aging of aspects of vision the eye is
largely a fluid sack when fluid vehicles
are blocked this is called glaucoma the
fluids can become stiffer what we call a
vitous humor can start to harden shift
pull away and you start to see floaters
oh I'm seeing one now there's another it
really bother me yeah I'm seeing the
this I got floaters they're usually
harmless little things they don't cause
any problems but if you see them you
should check them out maybe it's a tear
in the retina the eye is a direct window
onto the
brain
nose these are little bones that come
off the nose they're called turbinates
lined with specialized sensory
epithelium as we age we're losing many
of those cells in or Al Factory nerve we
lose the smaller cells in the covering
of the mucosa we do produce less mucus
it's there to catch odorant less mucus
less cells altered smells as our smell
decreases think of what happens when you
have a nose cold and both your nostrils
are blocked a potato and an apple will
taste the same what happens if you can't
appreciate the flavor of food we try to
pour more stuff onto it more salt oh God
you don't want to put more salt on
things that's throwing off all your
vascular systems if you don't eat you
start losing weight that's a dangerous
thing for many of the elderly you stop
wanting to go out to dinners you don't
socialize as much removing that can lead
to loneliness and can lead to depression
by the way many medications can change
your smell if you're noticing that the
pizza doesn't take tastes like the pizza
don't be
passive
skin skin is our biggest organ we have
proteins in the skin that are called
collagen and elastin giving structure
two aspects in our skin elastin gives us
the ability to move what happens when we
age these proteins start to decrease
skin all over the body starts to sand
underneath your arms breast tisues your
scrotum starts to Sag what is that
what's happening skin starts to Sag on
features of our face we get a down
turning we get the sad face this is
giving signals to our other primates
that say wo distance unhappy angry sad
bad they are negative Clues if I knew
stuff when I was 25 I wouldn't have sat
there and baked in the Sun for hours now
we know moisturize use
blockers
hair starting in the late 30s we lose
our follicles and hair starts to become
thinner this bone the side of my head is
called a temporal bone temporal means
time when you look on the side of your
head that's where you can first see hair
color starts to change the gray comes
because we lose melanin that's a major
signal to some 20-year-old that I'm old
you can knock me over and you can take
my piece of dinner to eat male pattern
baldness as our Androgen starts to go
down we're losing the top we're gaining
it elsewhere on our ears and our beard
and our nose hairs some of us start
looking like Chia Pets it's called the
Androgen Paradox it's a multi-billion
Dollar business to figure out how to
save the follicle it's not the easiest
thing to do this is really natural part
of life you don't have to have the same
hair you had when you were 18 but be
careful about lots of potentially
dangerous
chemicals
teeth so what's in our oral cavity our
tongue and also lots of glands these
glands are producing things that kill
bad bacteria as we age submandibular
sublingual glands paranid glands start
to decrease their secretions when
bacteria is allowed to spread it start
starts to affect the gums they start to
recede we lose the enamel of teeth what
happens when teeth are removed the bone
disappears if you have problems with
your upper dentici you can get a sinus
infection don't disregard your
teeth next the larynx the joints of the
larynx can age the muscles become
thinner the vocal folds start to shrink
and the mucus coverings start to
desiccate we can have arthritis in some
of them vocal folds when they're closed
together they create an ability to
stabilize our diaphragm when you're
constipated what you do is close your
vocal folds they enable you to use the
muscles of your abdominal wall to help
nature do its duty if these age and the
muscles weaken we get problems lifting
heavy objects and we start to have
problems with phonation and voice this
is known as pronia you can hear somebody
body and you can gauge whether they're
elderly just by the sounds coming from
their
voice
heart as we get into our 50s and our 60s
the heart muscles what we call our
myocardium start to lose oxygen it's
usually because of problems with the
arteries we get a hardening of the
arteries they become narrowed as they
narrow we have less oxygen going to the
heart we have a feature in our body
that's called collateral blood flow
where a structure or an organ gets blood
from various sources this is to make
sure that the structure is getting
sufficiently nourished our heart does
not have a lot of collateral flow if we
have the depth of tissue of the heart
the overlap of blood supply to the heart
is usually not sufficient to help that
heart muscle why not how come Evolution
glitched or species Homo sapiens came
about quarter of million years ago life
expectancy for our earliest ancesters
even of our species 40 plus years would
have been maxing out our heart seems to
run into problems in the 50s and 60s is
anybody who's built a house can tell you
you don't put in extra Plumbing if you
don't need
it uterus a female has to carry with her
uterus ovaries connecting uterine tubes
when females age past childbearing years
hormones are going to change estrogen is
going to shift the cells are continuing
to grow in abnormal ways the ovaries
become dangerous you can't assess
ovarian cancers that
easily prostate the prostate is
extremely important early on in giving
help in fluid to sperm as you get older
now it blossoms and as it grows the
urethra that goes through it becomes
blocked this starts to happen well into
the 30s into the 40s those of us that
are older we know what it is to get up
three four times a night to pee that's
because this prostate is not allowing
urine to have a healthy flow this is
normal aging prostate exams I can tell
you are not the most fun to do Doc is
trying to feel hardness which is an
indication of
cancer joints these are beautiful
structures is a patella is aema is a
tibia is a fibula along these areas are
magnificent structures called articular
cartilage when we lose it we can't
replace it joint deterioration can begin
in your 30s and 40s if you have abused
your joints stuff will start earlier
running is a very very important part of
our Evolution to get away from some lion
that wanted us for Sunday brunch on the
savanas of East Africa this didn't
evolve for playing football it didn't
evolve for pounding on concrete when
we've lost our little discs inside that
are called minisi we develop all sorts
of inflammation of joints that's called
arthritis want to run find a nice patch
of grass try swimming get off the
concrete don't send me eight
letters foot arguably the most important
least appreciated part of the human body
when you age we start to have issues
with vasculature the foot and hands are
the most distal parts of our body proper
circulation is essential when I go visit
my physician he would heal my feet to
see if they were warm to see if there
was good circulation blood flow is a key
to so much when we start to get reduced
blood flow we start to get losses of
sensation in the skin if that occurs you
can fall you often hear about people
breaking their hip because they lose
sensation often on the bottom of the
foot by the way for some of you that
have worn high heeled shoes for years
are you crazy course the end product is
going to be pinch toes decreased blood
supply damaged nerves remember your feet
these are key puppies if we're to remain
healthy and
Alive things change we have to deal with
that I still have problems realizing the
Dodgers left Brooklyn they're not coming
back I'm old I'm expensive but why do
the species keep us around it's called
wisdom and I'll trade in my knee for the
hug of one of my granddaughters any day
a